The internet has given the world so many amazing
things.
It’s mostly videos of cats in boxes or dogs
wearing boots for the first time.
But anyone who’s been online in the last
decade has probably come across something
else, too: memes.
While memes can draw inspiration from just
about anywhere, some of the most popular are
based on our favorite films!
Here are 10 Amazing Movies That Started Famous
Internet Memes.
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory,
There’s a skill to being condescending.
The speaker takes on the task of filling every
word with venom.
And the audacity it takes to look someone
in the eye while doing it?
Well, that takes the verbal assault to a whole
new level.
Since parts of the internet operate as a safe
space for grumps to be grumpy, we can see
why there’s a need for this kind of social
exchange to be meme-ified.
Thanks to some Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory fans, Condescending Wonka was born.
Using a frame from the Everlasting Gobstopper
sequence, users worldwide have been bonding
through sarcasm.
Even though in the context of the movie the
pose is fairly innocuous.
The Lord of the Rings: The Fellowship of the
Ring,
Given that The Lord of the Rings has been
building it’s following since the 1950’s,
it’s fair to say that at least a couple
people were excited after the three original
movies were announced.
When you have that much material to work with,
something’s bound to stick.
One scene shows the characters having a roundtable
about bringing the titular ring to Mordor.
Boromir (Sean Bean) describes the terrors
involved in the journey.
After feeling like the group is underestimating
the situation’s difficulty, he drops some
knowledge . It’s so perfect that people
use it when explaining how things might not
be what they seem.
The Matrix,
The Matrix introduced the world to a pile
of things we’d never seen: bullet time,
armless sunglasses, and a good Keanu Reeves
movie to name a few.
But it also gave us Morpheus.
The all-knowing, fearless leader of the unplugged
Nebuchadnezzar crew.
Much is made of the wizened ringleader’s
philosophical nature, and the other characters
are constantly looking to him for guidance.
The filmmakers did such a good job of this,
that his reputation extends beyond the confines
of his movie.
Memes with his face have sprung up all over,
and are often used to give relatively small
advice.
And depending on who you are, it will either
blow your mind or make you roll your eyes.
The Avengers,
Speaking of eye-rolling, you might have noticed
one of our favorite Avengers is guilty of
this offence.
In a blink and you’ll miss it moment, Iron
Man (Robert Downey Jr).
turns up the sass after Captain America (Chris
Evans) gives himself a pat on the back for
recognizing a Wizard of Oz reference.
Robert Downey Jr. delivers an eye roll that
puts all teenage girls to shame.
The frame is dripping with attitude, and since
everyone has their own pet peeves, it’s
become a symbol of indifference to some, while
others see it as a visual embodiment of the
phrase “here we go again”.
The Big Lebowski,
Have you ever felt like the only person on
earth who’s paying attention?
The only one following the rules?
Surprise!
You’re not actually alone!
Walter (John Goodman) from 1998’s The Big
Lebowski knows what you’re going through,
because he’s been there himself.
The gun-toting veteran is a stickler for regulations,
and isn’t afraid to call bullshit on violators.
After another guy at the movie’s bowling
alley goes off-book, Walter pulls his gun
and loudly wonders if he’s the only one
who “gives a shit about the rules”.
Of the people who treat the internet like
their own personal soapbox, Walter’s seems
to be the meme of choice.
Star Wars,
There’s no denying that the Star Wars movies
have had a huge impact on popular culture.
They’re some of the most-watched films ever
made, and the franchise has left it’s footprints
all over the place.
Trying to track down every single occurrence
would be a fool’s errand, so we’re not
even going to try.
And even in a conversation about memes, there
were a few Star Wars offerings to choose from.
But one of the most entertaining has to be
the Star Wars Kid.
It’s amazing what we humans will do to pass
the time.
Plus, who among us hasn’t imagined themselves
in the middle of a light saber duel?
Anchorman,
Anchorman is a veritable treasure trove of
epic quotes.
Written by Will Ferrell and Adam McKay, the
movie is hilarious from start to finish.
Farrell nails so many lines with his deadpan
delivery that if you’re not paying attention,
you’re bound to miss something great.
After a bloody brawl with some rivals, the
Channel Four News Team regroup over a beer
and talk about the fight.
Putting it mildly, Ron downplays the severity
of the days events with his even tone.
Someone realized that this scene delivers
the perfect out for anyone finding themselves
in a suddenly serious, awkward conversation.
300,
Zack Snyder’s take on 300 chronicles the
sweaty, topless battle at Thermopylae (“thurm-op-ah-lee”)
between the Spartans and Persians.
The movie did good things for a lot of industries;
gym memberships, leather briefs, and body
airbrushing all got really popular - for better
or for worse.
But one corner of the internet saw a different
opportunity, and turned the bloody flick into
one of the most enduring memes to date.
In one of the movie’s most serious moments,
Leonidas (Gerard Butler) is giving one hell
of a pump-up speech to the troops about dining
in hell.
And while his character yells a lot, this
scene is the one used most often in the memes.
The Great Gatsby,
There are tons of good occasions to throw
a quick cheers in the air before you get down
to drinking.
Birthdays, anniversaries, and graduations
are all reason enough to take that quick pause
before you get absolutely obliterated.
But after the release of 2013’s The Great
Gatsby, one particular salute spread like
wildfire.
When Gatsby’s character is finally introduced,
he raises his glass in a simple way, but the
insane pyrotechnics going off behind him makes
it truly epic.
People send the gif around as a glitzy way
to say “touché” to one other.
Sarcastic or not, it’s usually a genuine
pleasure to receive one.
Jumanji,
Have you ever played a game and wished that
it was real?
Anyone who’s ever seen Jumanji knows it’s
important to be careful what you wish for.
After being absorbed into the fabric of the
game decades earlier, Robin Williams’ character
is trapped for decades until two new players
unearth it and decide to roll the dice.
Since time didn’t stop for Williams, he
emerges from his purgatory a fully-grown man,
with the fully-grown beard to match.
As you can probably imagine, it’s hard to
keep track of the time when you’re stuck
in a board game.
So the first thing he wants to know is what
year it is.
What do you think of our list?
Did we skip over your favorite movie-based
meme?
Tell us about it in the comments below, and
subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.
Thanks for watching!